yeah I like one of the key things angel
said was listening as I think that's key
to a lot especially where you were
collaborating with with people and you
know because usually you know you know I
may have written a script but it's my
job to convey that you know and then
listen to what people listen to me and
they need a report back with what they
feel about you know the screenplay and
stuff and then we listen to each other
and we talked and we concocted we
collaborate and then that's how you come
to something organic together it is not
just do what I urge you to do there's no
passion in that did this passion and
that when everybody sees the same thing
and everybody feels the same thing and
then we all chased the same rabbit you
know and uh to me uh you know that
that's a big plus and he believed in me
from the first from the first time I'm
like you know it would take I never
taken no classes before right no you
could do it I locate the first time I
think the first audition after the
audition we had all the wheat the moves
reading the reading the script or what
I'm scared he was like to go to take
some classes my cuz yeah I'm do the wall
by hand on the shot you and all of this
video chip we get to act as we do a
reading angels reading like and I was
just like switched off and to end
everybody leave them like you couldn't
even like that is I don't know where we
got not just like okay now you're making
me nervous but I stuck with him in here
completely fooling around and they came
on the first you know for action on the
waiting is just nailing it not you're
like yeah there we go so they're like
where are we going what are we yeah yeah
but we made it work though what about
advice for just a working relationship I
mean you guys are friends before I know
you've worked together so you still had
that structure but sometimes people fall
apart especially in LA it's not easy to
friendships gone hmm respect I think I
think that was a number one thing we
both had for each other before we when
when Angela not meant we didn't really
talk I know if about a year and we
didn't really talk to each other what we
knew about each other and it was just
because of the environment in the
situation that we were in it was because
the only time we actually spoke is when
you know we were fighting so I was like
yeah he know you dealing with a
situation and then he would go to his
side of the club and I will go to my
side in a club and we really didn't
speak for like the first year and then
it was a but when I felt like I knew who
he was though so when we had that one
time driving in the car and he happened
to tell me that and it was just like and
I'm having a moment so should I be in
the in the in the short myself but at
the same time I kind of felt as a
director that was not wise because how
can you direct your first short and be
in it and make sure it's going to have
the look that you want if you're not
looking at it you're too immersed in it
your evo involved in you can't be that
involved in it so when when meeting
angel in riding in the car with him and
he he posed that you know you know they
need a project for me to see if I can
act and things like that I kind of
already had a gist for who he was as a
person and uh the one thing I held onto
I didn't know anything every good I but
the one thing I could hold on to was I
knew he could perform when the moment
came it's like some people have like a
light switch and some people could walk
around and you know you would they could
be the most unassuming person ever but
then when they're like oh it's time go
they could turn on the light switch and
now they're the most animated they're on
it they got so much energy and it's just
like angels one of those and a Leah very
low-key there that yep but I remove it
he's a fighter and I held onto that that
was the one thing that really you know
gelled us from the beginning was because
I fought in the ring before he's fought
in the ring before and in those moments
you deal with all of the same things
that
nervousness the people watching you
you're on camera all that those same you
know things that could you know make a
person shrink but he hasn't he's
performed in those moments and and when
I anytime I was nervous on the choice
you know my wife would say since I kind
of you know using new actor how do you
know he's going to be there you're
putting so much energy into this and you
don't know and I said that's why and now
we're always hanging the fact on if I
could do it in those moments and he and
you know in the ring and hold on to that
and do it he does it professionally so
you have to have a good understanding of
who you are as a person to jump into
those situations you know and thrive in
him and he does that and I counted on
him doing that for me and the weight he
did to me it's actually trust again I
never spoken we didn't talk for a year
nothing but I could be there could be a
fight going on in the club and I running
that by myself he could be all over the
second floor and I by the time I grabbed
one dude and I look to my left he's
right there grabbing grabbing another
direction I'm like you were just a daddy
again so fast you know so that's that's
how we build that relationship on that
trust so if you're going to work with
somebody make sure you trust him and
have faith and confidence spectra yeah
yeah we make up each other keep our word
yeah you keep your word if you say
you're gonna do something to do it you
know the meter in it and and if not
there's got to be a good reason and it
better be a big letdown for you I you
know one thing is that you know just as
a person especially when you know you're
grinding every you know you're in it all
the time and you want to meet people at
the same level of dedication and the
only way to know that is you know that
person has to be willing to take you
know not accept the loss but if the loss
comes it's got to be like the biggest
thing in the world so that it never
happens again and I don't like losses
that go by like oh yeah there's no big
deal no it's like a boulder hit me cuz
I'm gonna figure out how that boy
doesn't hit me ever again and we're
gonna move on and keep going and and
it's just like we're both stubborn we
gotta both flower qualities both
extremely stubborn and it works but it's
trustus all of those things mutual
respect and you know I think that's the
foundation for anything and you know
hopefully you know we can keep it going
you